welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Oppenheimer
the new Christopher Nolan biopic
explores the history behind the creation
of the atomic bomb and a figure who's
arguably one of the most important
people to ever walk the earth throughout
this video we're going to be discussing
the real life story behind him what
happens at the end of the movie and also
the aftermath of the entire thing heavy
spoilers ahead so if you're wanting to
go into the film without having anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
turn off now please hit the thumbs up
button and make sure you subscribe to
the channel if you want to see more
videos like this by the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
Oppenheimer
this is a national emergency
so Julius Robert Oppenheimer was born on
April 22nd 1904 credited as being the
father of the atomic bomb oppenheimer's
seen as a man who ended Wars but in turn
gave us the power to destroy ourselves
completely often we get quotes
attributed to Great Men and Oppenheimer
arguably has one of the most famous of
all time
now I am become deaf
the destroyer of worlds
this was added as he watched his
creation Light Up the Sky you know it's
attributed to him it actually pulls from
Hindu scripture the verse originally
States the Supreme lord said time I am
the great destroyer of worlds and I have
come here to destroy all people now this
has been changed slightly in the
translation but it can still be brought
across to what the scientists did
Oppenheimer someone adopted this to
usher in the successful testing of a
nuclear weapon and the context of it
carries a lot with it this is clearly a
man showing remorse and regret about the
damage that is seemingly great
achievement could now bring now before
the film's release I saw one of the best
written reviews for a movie that I'd
ever seen discussing the film daramuni
said it's about the gulf between theory
and practice intention and result the
folio of ego and the fear that any
effort to understand the forces
governing this chaotic World in which we
live in unleashes Madness it's an
incredible way to describe the movie and
I think it really gets to what it's
trying to drive home now for the next
part of the video want to discuss the
real life figure's life and some of the
techniques used to explore up in hymer's
history Nolan stated that the black and
white scenes are something that are
objectively true whereas the color ones
are somewhat subjective kinda feel like
this might even be a naughty Doctor
Strange Love though the scenes
themselves are far from a
tongue-in-cheek comedy Jack Howard also
discussed the making of process for this
and how Nolan actually wrote the script
as if it was in first person this really
allows you to get into the mind of him
and it makes for an incredible
experience on the big screen now
benheimer began his life in New York
City to his mother Ella and father
Julius an unobservant Jewish Family
they'd come to the US during 1888 and
this was in order to build a life for
themselves Robert's father had been
hired by a textile company upon arriving
and after working his way up he became a
wealthy executive this allowed the
family to move to an upper class area in
New York Anarchy Robert a great footing
to start his life off at his younger
brother Frank became a psychiatrist
Museum found out rise Robert became an
incredible chemist graduating in 1921 he
then joined Harvard and majored in
chemistry before moving to study in
Europe now whilst all this is going on
the path to the atomic bomb was also
coming into play ironically Oppenheimer
as we mentioned before was born in 1904
and this was also a significant year
where things fell into place elsewhere
at Cambridge University Frederick study
theorized that the energy within atoms
could be harnessed into a weapon which
would one day have the potential to
destroy the entire world he was scoffed
at but 13 years later the atom was split
by anist Rutherford and Research into
this continued at an alarming rate
Germany was at the Forefront of a lot of
these scientific discoveries however
their downfall was actually laced within
Hitler's bigoted views when he gained
power during 1933 he actually expelled
all of the Jewish scientists who'd been
part of the project and a lot of them
then fled to the US here they continued
their research as part of the man had
project which Oppenheimer would of
course come to head up now speaking of
Ernest Rutherford oppenheimerland in
1924 that he had been accepted into
Christ College Cambridge he contacted
Rutherford directly requesting to work
at the Cavendish laboratory but
unfortunately Ernest wasn't too
welcoming Oppenheimer was seen as
someone who was extremely clumsy unless
he had to pass a basic lab course before
he was welcomed in he did this but he
found it extremely boring with his true
passion being in theoretical physics
Oppenheimer was also pretty dislike
there too and this was due to some of
his really Disturbing Behavior he
actually poisoned an apple and left it
on the desk of a cheetah in the hopes
that he would then eat this however
luckily he didn't but Oppenheimer
admitted that he immediately regretted
doing this his parents were alerted by
the university and though probation was
threatened they didn't fact managed to
avoid this Oppenheimer apparently also
tried to strangle his friend with a
trunk strap at one point and the other
guy is often pay it out in a good light
he cleared really had this darker side
too now whatever the man did at
University didn't hold him back and his
talent clearly kept opening up doors for
him eventually he secured a job at the
University of California which is where
he had a faithful meeting with Gene
tatlock played by Florence Pugh she
becomes a key character in the film and
is arguably one of the most crucial
people in his life a member of the
Communist party was suspected the pair
were politically aligned and this
eventually led to the FBI opening up a
file on him though he didn't join them
this sowed the seeds for his downfall
which we'll talk more about later on in
the video now even with his politics by
1941 he was selected to take part in the
Manhattan Project selecting a sign Los
almanos New Mexico the movie of course
brings the creation of their work to
life it really shows everything that
went into it and we get all the
intensity behind just how much of a race
this was to build the bomb
build a town build it fast he's only
scientists ring their families who never
get the best
I was also at this location that
Oppenheimer slipped up and unfortunately
this built off the back of what we
talked about before Oppenheimer was
approached to pass his discoveries on of
the Soviet Union which he ended up
actually turning down however because he
didn't report it to the authorities this
eventually caused problems and lots of
mistrust around him as we see in the
film he also had an affair with tatlock
despite being married with two kids this
was to a woman named Kitty who in the
films played by Emily Blunt tatlock
being so close to the Communists at the
FBI tapping his phone and this was to
see if he was in fact selling off
Secrets later on in 1949 the Soviets
managed to make progress on their bomb
and they tested it before the us
predicted that they'd have the capacity
to was believed that someone had been
selling them Secrets which led to eyes
further falling on Oppenheimer earlier
on in their lives tatlock 2 was
questioned and this all came to a head
in 1944 she ended up taking her own life
at the age of just 29 and this was after
suffering from from clinical depression
the war itself start drawing close to an
end when Hitler took his own life in
1945 however the Japanese were still all
in on it and as a nation they refused to
back down thus the developments
continued and with the help from British
scientists the first bomb detonation
took place on July 16th Nolan captures
this moment incredibly in the film and
as I'm sure you know he detonated a real
bomb now this was in a nuke obviously
but it shows how much effort he put into
making this movie the guy tried to use
as little CGI as possible and though
there's computer generated effects they
are kept to a minimum also it is a bit
weird doing this video and having to
give spoiler warnings and stuff because
I'm starting to think is it a spoiler if
it's history
wait a minute you didn't learn how World
War II ended
we won
[Applause]
now the bomb was suspended from a tower
and upon its detonation it destroyed 4
800 feet the tower itself was instantly
reduced to atoms and even the sand
surrounding it was instantly turned to
Glass now because of this the project
was seen as a success but what came next
of course changed the world Humanity now
had a weapon that almost matched the
power of God in its destructive force
was nothing like the world had ever seen
coming in at 18.6 kilotins this was
equivalent to every single bomb dropped
on London throughout the entire Blitz
after this point the plan shifted to
what would happen in Japan and how the
country was gonna win the war Japan was
actually offered the chance to surrender
with them being warned that die
consequences would occur if they refused
to leaflets were drop warning citizens
that the bomb was coming and they were
told that they had to escape that didn't
happen though and as mentioned earlier
the country refused to give up the bomb
was built and it was loaded onto the
Enola Gay carrying the message greetings
to the emperor it was dry on August 6
1945 and as we know the world would
never be the same again the bomb
instantly killed sixty thousand people
and a survivor of it recently spoke to
the Today Show about what they witnessed
there was a lot of commotion and there
was uh people were saying that there was
a B-29 coming or towards the Hiroshima
American Howard coquita was seven years
old living with his grandparents near
hiroshima's Ground Zero
so my brother and I his name is Kenny my
older brother he and I we climbed on top
of a wolf who watched the vapor trail
and fortunately my grandmother being
much smarter than us she told us to get
off the roof an act that saved their
lives I didn't see the flash I didn't
hear the boom I was knocked out
instantaneously when I came to which is
I'm sure a number of minutes later the
structure was on top of me and things
are beginning to burn around me somehow
Howard his brother and grandmother
survived this was not an ordinary bomb
but it was something much bigger
everything was burning they saw things
no person should witness there were
already a number of people that were
there along the roadside people was
burned suffering and then you know
begging for a drink of water some of the
injuries so so severe that for example
people with Burns their skins would be
dripping from their bodies and some of
the people actually have broken them so
you know protruding when we came back
after the uh the surrender
we came back to the same area and the
whole city was completely flat it was
really devastating to see radiation of
course filled the air and many people
lost their hair with some even dying of
cancer shortly after in total the
bombing is said to have led to the
deaths of 130 000 people low Judo Ola
was being instantly disintegrated the
true number will never be known
obviously looking back there's a lot of
debate over whether this was the right
thing to do as many of the people killed
weren't involved in the war per se they
were just part of the nation and with
many of the victims being children a lot
of people feel it was an extremely
tragic event even the pilot of the
plane's logbook had him feeling
remorseful with him questioning how many
people that he just helped to kill this
is something the film focuses on too but
the argument in favor of it is that it
helped end the war however there would
be more Bloodshed to come and the
Japanese government still wouldn't
surrender they were lost in confusion
over what had just happened as they were
just unable to communicate with the
military radio towers and had no idea
what was going on they sent someone out
to survey the area and report back what
they saw and all this person could see
was a giant smoke cloud in the sky Upon
returning the leader surmise that not
many bombs like this could be quickly
developed and thus they decided to
endure and continue the war the second
bomb was dropped on Nagasaki just three
days later and eventually the Japanese
gave up and decided to surrender
Oppenheimer left Los Alamos in October
1945 with an intense feeling of Guild
which he expressed to President Truman
meeting him in the Oval Office he said
he had blood in his hands which Truman
remarked would come off in the wash
Truman would later state that he was a
crybaby scientist and that he didn't
ever want to see him in his office again
Oppenheimer refused to support a
hydrogen bomb project and this ended up
angering the officials out in Washington
in 1945 Oppenheimer was called in to
explain his communist affiliations and
this was after years of suspicions
fueled by Lewis Strauss played by Robert
Downey Junior the real life figure
carried the same Grudge that we see in
the film humiliated in front of Congress
yes prior he'd harbing a grudge against
him and eventually this led to
oppenheimer's ousting these are all
things which the film beautifully
demonstrates and Strauss becomes the
antagonist to hoppenheimer that wants to
ruin his career believing he was a
Soviet spy it proved to be his undoing
and he was shortly stripped of his clear
ends and deemed a security risk these
scenes are laced throughout the film and
they build towards the ending which
we'll talk about in just a bit on a
closed room hearing that lasted four
weeks he was instructed to give detail
of all his personal affairs his friends
turn against him and he found himself an
outcast even though In the Airs
following bias of the hearings came out
they clearly showed that Oppenheimer was
loyal to the US but refusing to continue
building weapons had people turn against
him Joe Biden's Administration actually
formally reversed the decision recently
which in the end has exonerated
Oppenheimer at the time there was was
uproar too with Einstein calling it a
conspiracy and Werner Von Braun saying
that in England he would have been given
a Knighthood and the aftermath of this
Oppenheimer actually rallied against the
use of nuclear weapons and stated that
you can't really Target specific
individuals and thus civilians will
always be caught in the blast he also
believed that there'd be an arm race
specifically with the Soviets and as we
know we ended up getting the Cold War
however things change with the altering
of administrations and JFK was far more
welcoming to him than what had come
before he offered him a retrial but
Oppenheimer declined however a little
over a week after JFK's assassination he
accepted an award from president Lyndon
this announced all his achievements in
physics and it was somewhat an olive
branched directly from the government
now this summer plays into the ending of
the film and in case you're watching
this without seeing it the final scene
has to do with the conversation he has
with Einstein throughout the movie we
get a tease towards it an earlier
Strauss witness stop in high Moran
Einstein talking Einstein leaves the
conversation and Lewis tries to talk to
him but the scientist just walks right
by without even giving him a glance they
cut around it and that points you
wondering exactly what it is that
Einstein said in the final scene we get
to check out this conversation in full
and here for ourselves all the words
exchanged Einstein said that he'd be
regarded highly by the government and
that one day they would end up honoring
him however he said they'd be doing it
for themselves rather than for him man
all in all it was just a big Pat on
their own backs while this is going on
we see him receiving his award
surrounded by those that gave the
negative testimonies now at its most
basic level is it common on how the
government and scientific Community used
him to win the war because of their seal
now some won't be shown off like a
trophy that they can just parade around
even though he'll be given the Limelight
it will always be self-serving with them
not caring about the costs that it
actually had on him the world will very
much cheer him up and spit him out which
in many ways is what straw represents
oppenheim is standing up against the
hydrogen bomb means that they're on a
front to him now and we all know about
what he had to go through Einstein walks
away and he stares into the pond
wondering if his actions will one day
lead to the downfall of humanity
recalling a prior conversation he thinks
about how triggering the bomb could lead
to a chain of events that could
potentially destroy all life on Earth he
contemplates whether his actions will
inadvertently lead to this and we see an
earth covered in nuclear missile impact
points painting out a harrowing picture
this of course has a double meaning as
originally the talk was about how
building that specific bomb could
trigger things to get destroyed across
the entire planet in one foul swoop
however Nolan here is dealing with the
idea of escalation it's a theme he's
tackled before and at the end of Batman
Begins we had Gordon talking to Batman
about this if they get knives their
enemies will get guns and if they get
guns their enemies will get
armor-piercing rounds the race aren't
stop and it'll be a constant struggle to
stay one step ahead of everyone one
which will lead to building bigger
weapons them triggering that first bomb
caused other countries to have to build
them too and the hydrogen bomb is in the
end goal it's simply the next step after
that who knows and there will be a
constant upping of weapons across the
planet now a hydrogen bomb has never
been fired in war but it has been tested
Brynn did it as well and it shows how
we've even had to up our arms in order
to get to a point where we can rival the
rest of the world it's owning stuff and
on the opposite side of this
conversation is Lewis Strauss throughout
the movie It's shown that not only the
Congress hearing hurt him but also the
paranoia of us seeing these two talking
as he approached the pair Einstein
walked away completely ignoring Lewis
and this is due to what he represents
he's very much a figurehead of the
government that would turn on
Oppenheimer and he likely realizes
exactly what he is now this paranoia
goes on to make Strauss hey Oppenheimer
and intern this leads to his own
downfall Strauss would later attempt to
get a higher position in the government
but his medal and accusations of
Oppenheimer worldly to his undoing his
hand in it eventually was exposed
leading to him not getting the job and
both the pair's Ambitions have left them
at a loss the film asks if and trying to
achieve things we ultimately lead to our
own ends then that is something I think
schematic throughout the movie both
Strauss and Oppenheimer will race to get
ahead but ultimately neither will really
come out winning now all scientific
discoveries can potentially come with a
dilemma of what it actually costs to
achieve the things we want Oppenheimer
created a bomb that ended up stopping
the war but in turn ushered in a new age
of humanity now his legacy is still felt
on everything today however Oppenheimer
didn't live too long after the events of
the film in 1967 he died due to throat
cancer said to be brought on by prolific
smoking I will always be looked back on
as the person who built the bomb that
ended the most devastating War
Humanity's ever faced from this Pawn on
the Warfare changed drastically and
instead we headed towards more cold Wars
for with Espionage and tactics the
threat of nukes has kept other countries
from using them as we have seen
firsthand how destructive they can be
Humanity luckily realized how
devastating bombs like this are and they
rightfully held off using them due to
the fear they could be used back over in
the case of Oppenheimer he of course
witnessed what his work did and it's
unlikely that he peacefully passed
having a warm feeling about his work her
deaths caused by them still can't be
counted and it's clearly a complex issue
that people still debate that's what
Nolan's work brings to life as well and
it's an incredible accomplishment on
every single level
[Music]
foreign
as I'm sure many of you know I'm a
die-hard Nolan fan I think the guy's an
incredible writer director and lastly
editor that manages to tell sometimes
incredibly complex stories in a really
thrilling way I think that's the case
here too when he brings together all of
his Styles and talent to tell us
oppenheimer's story it beautifully
adapts the American Prometheus book and
manages to handle his entire life
constantly jumping back and forth
between timelines to show how the past
affected the future now because of this
I think some people might get lost
especially when trying to discern what's
happening when Nolan does separate this
a lot of the time with black and white
and they actually built special IMAX
cameras for this as by default they're
built they were built when Color Film
was readily available so they never had
that functionality and only however he
just did it for this movie the guys
clearly put a ton of effort into this
film and he's elevated everything that
he could to tell just a very complex
story there's themes tackling the cult
of personality and how Creations get
taken out the hands of the Creator and
then giving you Life by people who have
more nefarious means I also don't think
I've ever seen a movie since I last
watched 2001 that was so wash with color
vivid imagery and a score that beats
away and drives the action immersion is
the word here and the film sucks your
eye in especially in IMAX Killian Murphy
becomes Robert Oppenheimer and I was
actually surprised at how many faces
there are considering the budget for
this is just 100 million I'm guessing
all these actors drop their prices to
work with Nolan because the director
yeah he's easily one of the best alive
and that doesn't mean the movie's
perfect and I actually thought the bomb
itself was pretty underwhelming for that
to be the big thing they've hyped up for
months now due to them really setting
one off I was expecting it to be big but
I think this is a shot that you could
have actually used CGI for Don't Shoot
Me Nolan just my opinion and I also
thought the JFK name drop was I don't
know kind kind of like when they say
Robin at the end of The Dark Knight
Rises it felt like a sort of sequel
setup thing rather than being a natural
line of dialogue but I am nitpicking
there it's just something that stood out
to me now the movie also drops a bit
after the bomb drops and then you have
the Arrow air kind of just goes through
most of the hearing still brilliant but
yeah I think he could have cut things
out without losing much of the movie's
impact also the I am deathline I'm never
gonna look at that line in the same way
again because of how they have him
saying it as he slips it in should be I
am death the destroyer of girls terrible
now at the end of the day though yeah
we'll move we'll move on and the impact
is what stays with me and that ending
especially is something that I'm gonna
remember for a while the film opens with
raindrop setting a puddle and it's
ending with the pawn perfectly brings it
all full circle it shows how an idea can
start small and then grown to something
big and perfectly tells the dangers of
Discovery curiosity kill the cat is the
moral of this story and it begs the
question of whether any weapon like this
is worth the cost that comes with it
overall I was blown away by the movie
pun not intended and this was an
exhilarating experience for the the full
three hours I really enjoyed seeing it
and though the movie's not for everyone
it's definitely one of the best films of
the year
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Oppenheimer and also what
you took from the movie specifically
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed the video please hit the thumbs
up button and don't forget to subscribe
for videos like this every day if you
want something else to watch them make
sure you check out a video on screen
right now and I know I've been a bit you
know kind of tower in this I've been
trying to be respectful uh but yeah you
might have more fun over at one of them
without the way huge thank you for
singing through the video I really
appreciate you sitting up till now I've
been your house Paul and I'll see you
next time take care peace